مقطع الفيديو هذا تقول السلطات في كييف
انها صورته في احدى جبهات القتال في
باخماد يظهر جنديا روسيا وهو يستسلم بعدما
سقط كل رفقه الجندي تلقى تعليمات كتب
عليها لا تقاوم وتتبع المسيره الاوكرانيه
من المستحيل التحقق من تاريخه او مكاني
مقطع الفيديو هذا لكن في الاونه الاخيره
القوات الاوكرانيه اكد التقدمها مئات
الامطار في بعض نقاط القتال
حتى قائد مجموعه فاغنر الخاصه اعترف ببعض
الخسائر
كان ماكيرا لان قوته بدات الهجوم المضاد
القوه الاوكرانيه تتقدم على الجوانب
باتجاه المدينه محققه بعض النجاحات للاسف
تعرف مدينه بخموت منذ تسعه اشهر صمود
القوات الاوكرانيه في وجه مجموعه فاجنر
المسيطر على اكثر من 90% من مساحه المدينه
كما تسعى فاجنر الى اختراق بخموت لفتح
الطريق امام الجيش الروسي نحو مدينه
كراماتورس كاستراتيجيه
لم يحققوا اي انتصار منذ شهر مايو العام
الماضي هذا امر كارثي بالنسبه للروس
وفاكنير قد زجت بالجيش الروسي في خيارها
مدينه ذات رمزيه لكل من كييف وموسكو
وانتصار طرف على اخر قد يكون بدايه لتحول
المعطيات الميدانيه في اوكرانيا